the jurgen experience
chuck norris movies of the [ __ ]
i loved all those movies right all the
bruce lee movies
came through bruce lee obviously but
what he did was made [ __ ] where it was
like it was a little more believable
that he was [ __ ] these guys up in my
eye as a lifelong martial artist in my
eyes i was like this is all real this
could go down this way okay the way he
[ __ ] these guys up and also he looks
like a mean [ __ ]
when he was young and thin steven seagal
looked mean as [ __ ] and i believed it
when he was [ __ ] guys up it wasn't
like pierce bronson head kicking people
you know what i'm saying that was fake
yeah you i'm watching this guy i'm like
this is a guy who knows like real john
i'm looking in his eyes like you look in
bruce lee's eyes you look in chuck
norris's eyes those are people that
really know how to [ __ ] people up you
can see it in their eyes yeah and i can
see it in his eyes he knows how to [ __ ]
people up i mean it's like
a bad damn he knows how to [ __ ] people
up definitely jean-claude van damme was
a legit martial artist absolutely legit
martial artist so those four basically
though there's a quite a few of them man
you know michael j white is michael
jackson
absolutely legit michael j white broke
the chain on the heavy bag at legends
gym in hollywood he asked eddie bravo or
eddie bravo brother asked him to
demonstrate uh the way he does a
sidekick this dude does a sidekick a
hopping sidekick slams it into the bag
the bag goes could take against the
chain and the
that's real 100 real we were laughing
because me and eddie were like dude if
this was a movie and the guy came over
like the movie star is gonna demonstrate
that he really knows karate and he does
the kick and it breaks the bag he'd be
like get the [ __ ] out of here with this
movie maybe that's what i'm saying and
we were laughing our asses off but he
really did it michael j white he has
perfect technique
perfect there's a bunch of
demonstrations of him kicking online let
me tell you something the diet guy has
perfect technique there's guys that
maybe their knee is down too much or
maybe when they throw a yeah dude i'm
telling you perfect technique
everything he does 100
hip engagement
you know like
when you watch him hit the bag well
remember when he played tyson dawg i was
about to say that's my favorite role he
ever did
or spawn remember we played
right he was amazing in spawn
but he has a bunch of videos of him
demonstrating martial arts online he
even did like a thing with kimbo they
were working on a movie together and he
was explaining something to kimbo about
telegraphing things and kimbo was you
could tell kimbo was like oh [ __ ] it
wasn't just like an actor was [ __ ]
around it was like oh this guy's legit
i've watched him man i'm telling you i
know legit martial arts michael jai
white very legit
wesley snipes very legit very legitimate
stand up very legit stand up 100 black
belt level stand up let's go like you
watch him [ __ ] people up in in um
blatantly that's a hundred percent
wesley snipes yeah he went hard yeah no
he's good but michael j white had a
bunch of fights michael jackson a bunch
of [ __ ] yeah he had a bunch of kyokushin
fights michael j y is legit
and you watch him like move around is
that him with john but josh barnett
cowboy
i thought they were really going after
me they weren't really dog has he been
on the podcast
no he hasn't i definitely have mine
though i did a thing with him like back
in the day in like 1994 i was hosting i
was a guest host of later remember bob
costa's head later and i got i got him
out as on as a guest okay i wanted to
talk to him 94. oh dude it was back in
the disney might have been 95. maybe it
might have been even 96. but it was in
the 90s
like so it was like i think he was right
when he was doing the tyson movie
and i was asking about like because you
know 96 tyson was still young and
terrifying that was a risky time to play
him
you know